if you don't have enough time carved out
in your life for your mind to wander
you're not accessing
the best part of yourself
don't be late
don't set expectations for someone and
not meet them the closer you get to your
goals will be a reflection of what you
are putting in your calendar wanna be
happy build a life not just a business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn what
billionaires do in their daily routine
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one
meditate with sean combs
what is your strategy for dealing with
distractions
that's a great question
yes
something that
is that you've heard about
you've heard about this
but it's that thing like are you willing
to go to where you need to go and get
out your comfort zone
the number one thing that has been able
to help me with
distractions is two things
one of them is prayer
just taking two minutes
to quiet everything out and talk to god
and then the second thing which i was
like i can't do this like
i can't even believe i said that
it's meditation
meditation
if
if that's one thing you'll take away
which which from today is just go on
youtube and say 10 minute meditation
smooth music some type in anything 10
minute meditation i got to go see my
girl she mad at me you know what i'm
saying
whatever it is
type it in
and
and just just really kind of clear your
mind rule number two find your thinking
time with sarah blakely i have four
children under the age of eight he
turned to eight last week so um time
alone is even more sacred and it's a
time that i absolutely need to carve out
for myself so one of the things that i
did is i found out when my best thinking
time is and it's in the car
so i live only five or six minutes from
the spanx headquarters but i actually
many times leave my house an hour before
i need to be at work and go on a fake
commute
so my friends have laughed and called it
my fake commute but i realized that's
when my mind wanders and
and that's when my ideas come to me and
so i have to carve that time out so i'm
driving around with all the other
commuters and i'm like the happy
commuter because i and i don't ever have
an agenda of where i'm going sometimes
i'm in inman park sometimes i end up in
downtown sometimes i'm in decatur i just
drive around
and there must be something for me about
the activity of driving and being able
to think and just listen to some
background music that accesses a certain
part of my brain and i read the other
day that einstein had all his best ideas
when he was shaving and so there must be
something about a rote activity that
you're doing that allows you to at least
at least for me it's driving so that's
one thing that i would say that i do so
find out and identify when your best
think time is and and make sure you're
you're making that happen in your life
and i'm not talking about when you're
just going through your checklist of
everything you have to do i'm talking
about when does your mind wander
and if you don't have enough time carved
out in your life for your mind to wander
you're not accessing the best part of
yourself
because there's there's a knowing inside
of you and it's when you're when you're
in that space not when you're watching
tv and not you know it's even more
difficult now with how much distractions
we have from ourselves rule number three
write things down with kevin o'leary i'm
going to share a little trick with you
and all viewers
see these pencils here on my desk i've
got these all over the place i got
probably thousands of these
and i have
this this is the lowest tech thing
you've ever seen sticky note
during the day here's one i just this
morning
i write down things i have to get done
i know it's slow tech there's all kinds
of software can do this for you i don't
care
i like pulling a pencil and simply
writing down oh yeah i got to get that
thing done and just
making that note
i learned this from a very successful
person years and years ago my mother
and
this note
just sits here all day and at night if i
haven't finished and usually there's
three or four i haven't done i look at
it and say
okay
tomorrow
i will get this done
before anything else before you know i i
go online before i read anything you
know i go watch television before i make
any phone calls or texts or anything
i'm gonna get this thing done and i
stick it on the mirror on the right hand
side
number one
record baseline for track 15. all right
so i found a piece of music that i
recorded back in 89 i'm working on a
documentary about uh watch dials which i
think you're going to find interesting
when i finally get it finished but it
needs the music so the editors can work
with the beat of the music
and this thing i recorded in 89 does not
have any bass and i didn't play bass
back then now i do so i'm going to go
back in the studio and lay down the bass
track for track 15.
[Music]
number two
reconcile foreign currency i have
investments
over in europe and
each month i reconcile to the currency
to figure out how much of the
performance was gained or lost by the
change in the currency rates so i want
to do that this morning it's important
to get that done for last month because
you know
if you don't have that information you
can't make moves and
number three
tape questions four and five for tax
hive tax hive is a new business i've got
involved in as an investor and also as a
spokesperson
this is a company that helps small
business with their taxes and payrolls
very important in my portfolio companies
so i'm recording some messages and four
and five have to be done today so i'm
gonna go in the studio and record those
great take that's the one before i do
anything else today these three puppies
are gonna get done and that is how you
get super productive and you don't let
anything distract you you don't take a
phone call you don't do emails you don't
do anything you get the things done that
you made the priorities the night before
do it every day try it it's fantastic
look at this low tech
low tech you write it down a piece of
paper stick it on the mirror come on it
works rule number four show up no matter
what with grant cardone at different
places
in life i promise you
you're gonna find you don't know where
to go
everybody goes through this the most
successful people in the world wake up
some mornings
with no clue
what to do today
okay so first thing i want you to know
is that it's normal it happens to
everybody it's not like you're a bad
person or you're lost or you're
depressed or
you you got some problem you need to
take medication for everybody everybody
regardless their stature in life where
they are regardless of their money their
relationship
their job they run the joint
promise you no matter how much they
present
like they look like they got the whole
package put together everybody everybody
has those days
and the sun is kicking today has those
days
where uh
they don't know what to do
i don't know what to do
you know uncertainty show up even if you
you feel terrible my friend dale
christensen told me when i was 25 years
old i was experiencing depression every
day he's like
no matter what man no matter what
no matter what dude show up even if your
eyes are bleeding show up i've been
doing that for 34 years now show up even
when i don't want to okay and then what
i try to do is i try to help one person
one person
and what happened over the period of 34
years i did that every day i'm not
depressed anymore at least not for long
periods of time i don't use any kind of
medication don't use any kind of drugs
don't smoke weed don't drink over
excessively drink i might have a drink
once in a while
and um
got a beautiful wife two beautiful kids
and for the most part my life is
freaking wonderful all i did was this i
don't over analyze
never do i label myself a loser a
quitter
um
i'm hard on myself i never i never label
myself ocd acd add
ocdd whatever a depressant uh alcohol
like a drug addict no no i don't this is
what i do i do things okay show up
move in the direction i don't
overanalyze moving the direction that
that that i think could be
more pro-survival than staying in one
place and number three
help somebody hey man how you doing
buddy good how are you you got a book
coming out don't you
uh you just came out where can people
get it
get it on amazon easiest spot built to
serve right there
let's go man if you guys don't know evan
follow evan carmichael he's got a new
book out build a serve go grab it today
at amazon
there's a good dude right here rule
number five channel your intentions with
robin sharma there's a lot of emerging
science saying here's the reality and
anyone who wants to dismiss it is
denying science which is planet earth is
a tiny planet in a galaxy of trillions
of planets
my friend deepak chopra was on my stage
uh at one of my events a few months ago
he's a lovely man he just radiates
goodness
and
he took us on a tour de force about
cosmology and he's been a pioneer for so
many years and he confirmed the science
which is we are all part of an energy
source whatever you want to call it god
uh nature life and you're absolutely
right jay your intentions are creative
so we could come at it from a cosmo
cosmological point of view when you say
here's who i want to be you know this
morning in my journaling i'm gonna meet
jay
i'm so delighted and blessed that he's
invited me on his show because he
influences so many people how may i
serve
that intention
hopefully is creative so we're very
powerful
i'll come at it another way which is
epigenetics
epigenetics as you know
stands for the emerging field of science
which is you are not your genome the old
school said your dna what you get from
mom and dad that's your destiny we're
now realizing that epigenetics means
our environment our daily rituals like
getting up at 5 00 a.m our thoughts what
we eat our peer group etc
literally affects the up regulation or
down regulation of our genome
what does that mean it means
if you believe in yourself if you do the
work in the journaling if you get up at
5 00 am and do that victory hour and go
through the 20 20 20 formula you
literally are recalibrating who you will
become out in the world so you're
absolutely right then you start
channeling your intentions
and you start stepping into your power
like we are awesomely powerful beings
most of us have blocked our our intimacy
with our true power rule number six have
a routine with jack dorsey what i want
to talk to you about today is a note
which i call daily
so if you create a new note in your
notepad or something that you check on a
daily basis this is the most important
thing
name it daily
and then write the word do
colon
and then go down a few lines and write
the word don't
colon
the one thing i would ask you to do
walking out of this
is to
every single day just for a week
wake up to this note
check it throughout the day
and then also before you fall asleep
check to make sure that you did and you
didn't do everything so what you put in
each one of these is you have a list of
everything that you want to do every
single day and you have a list of things
that you don't want to do and the
easiest way to add to the don'ts
is to notice something that you never
want to do it again you never want to do
again
and you just add that to it
very very simple i'm just going to share
some of mine these might be a little bit
personal and embarrassing but here we
are
number one on my do list is to stay
present
i think it's so easy to get trapped in
the past
it's so easy to think about the future
the most important thing is i stay
present and just reading this
brings me back to the present brings me
back
to this moment
number two for me is be vulnerable
show people my mistakes
show people my fears
because they can relate
because they're going through similar
things
number three
drink only lemon water
and red wine
great red wine is a great modifier for
it this goes with one of my don't which
is don't drink hard liquor or beer on
weekdays
number three is
six sets of 20 squats
and push-ups
throughout the day i just have to do
them every day
uh six sets of 30-second planks
run for three miles
meditate on this list
stand up straight
which whenever i say i always see
posture moving in the audience
say hello to everyone
i just bought a heavy bag so i'm
training with a heavy bag so i want to
spend 10 minutes with a heavy bag every
day
i want to do a video journal every
single day and i want to get seven hours
of sleep
on my don't list and again this is one
of the hardest things and a lot of these
are personal so i'm not going to read
all of
them well my don't list is don't avoid
eye contact
don't be late
don't set expectations for someone and
not meet them
don't eat sugar
i'm on the paleo diet so don't eat wheat
lentils or dairy
and then of course don't drink hard
liquor or beer on the weekdays
um so this list well it sounds very very
simple has been fundamental in
establishing patterns for myself
and it's something that i do check every
single morning i check throughout the
day and i check right before i go to bed
and i make sure that i check everything
off
and go through it i've given it to our
companies
i've given it to a number of students
that i've talked to as we've gone to
schools and recruiting and people have
come back to me and said that this is
something that works for me it's
something that's easy to do and
something easy to remember
one of the most fundamental things about
it that i've learned that i've taken
away from it is how it gives you focus
how it gives you something that allows
you to really ignore
everything else that's going on all the
other noise to allow you to focus on
what's most important so this do and
don't list for people and individuals in
the company has translated to a do and
don't list for our company
for square we have a do and don't list
we have these are the things that we're
going to do these are the core things
these are our bold bets and these are
the things we're saying no too for right
now
has been fundamental in allowing us to
move fast to continue to innovate and to
really push the boundaries and continue
and question and and reset everything
that we think about the organization
rule number seven visualize with john
assaraf if you think about
visualization is simulation
now here is the difference whoa
that's good okay go ahead so
visualization is simulation so when we
close our eyes or even if our eyes are
open and we start to use our einstein
brain the imagination
we now have just activated one of the
biggest centers of our brain the
occipital lobe that's connected to the
motor cortex it's connected to the
motivational circuit the nucleus comes
that releases that dopamine that makes
you feel good that makes you want to
take action so if you
visualize
yourself achieving the goal if you
visualize yourself behaving in ways that
match the new belief if you even
visualize the words or you take the
words on a sheet of paper and you read
them run your right finger across it run
your left finger across it close your
eyes see it and feel it your brain is
creating a mental movie with the words
and as it creates a mental movie with
the words that's happening in your
subconscious mind
and when you give the subconscious these
instructions a couple things happen
because of the way the brain hierarchy
works number one it's survival but then
number two is safety
and then number three is energy
conservation now when you do something
20 30 40 50 times it takes about 66 days
to
365 days of repetition to override an
old habitual circuit not 10 days not 21
days 66 to 365. so if you visualize
yourself achieving the goal feeling the
success that you want to feel
seeing the belief on the screen of your
mind you are actually creating a neural
network through the science of
neuroplasticity
and the networks that you reinforce
become the most dominant networks and
since your brain wants to conserve
energy
if you do this on a consistent basis
your brain says okay
you're doing this so often let me just
make this automatic let me set aside the
old beliefs let me replace it with the
new beliefs and now you've deliberately
and consciously evolved yourself and
rule number eight the last one before
some very special bonus clips is follow
energy with mel robbins here's your new
definition of passion
passion is simply
energy
that's all that it is okay
passion
is what you feel
when you are energized and excited
about what you're doing okay i want you
to think about that for a minute i want
you to think about a moment in time
when you felt incredibly passionate
about something okay and why don't you
in the comments tell me where are you
watching from and tell me about a moment
in time when you felt incredibly
passionate about what you were doing
about where you were
about the people that you are with
describe that moment for me because when
you start to
really investigate
passion as energy
this is what you're going to discover
those moments when you're super
passionate like i'm sure my kids would
write down when they're doing community
theater with all their friends
i would write down whenever i'm doing
any kind of creative project with my
team
i'm incredibly energized whenever i'm
doing group
exercise stuff climbing a mountain
doing a 5k race doing some sort of
walk-a-thon i'm incredibly energized by
that whenever i'm um doing some sort of
creative project incredibly energized by
that whenever i'm working with our video
team incredibly energized by that
whenever i am
coaching someone or giving advice i am
incredibly energized by that and so what
i want you to understand is that if you
look back on your life you have had
moments where you have felt
passion i'm being very deliberate in how
i'm talking this morning on coffee talk
because passion is a huge topic for so
many of you and you've been so focused
on trying to figure out what job is
going to make me uh passionate what job
is my passion what is my purpose on the
earth i'm going to tell you what your
purpose on earth is right now
your purpose on earth is to figure out
how to align your life so that you feel
more energized and excited by it that's
it
and it begins with you
following the energy and following your
natural enthusiasm you're not going to
think your way to passion you can't
think your way to finding something that
you feel in your heart it doesn't work
that way you got to feel your way into
it it's inside of you do you understand
there's no passion out there somewhere
the passion is in here and so what you
have to do first is you've got to stop
thinking that you're going to find it
somewhere and you've got to realize that
passion is about unlocking something
that's already in you
and so here's the thing
so for those of you that have been
watching coffee talk for a while or
you've read the five second rule book or
maybe used the five second journal or
maybe you took mindset reset with us
this january
you've probably heard me talk about the
fact that inside of you there is power
you have an inner compass
and that inner compass is always guiding
you and learning how to read that inner
compass is essential if you want to
unlock the passion that's already
naturally inside you
passion again isn't a person place or
thing that you're going to find it is a
state of being that you unlock inside of
yourself and it is there and you can tap
into it right now
so there is an inner compass inside of
you that i call an energy gauge
it's an energy gauge that reads the
energy in you and around you and that
energy gauge goes from moments when you
feel depleted dead and empty to moments
where on the other side of the gauge you
feel energized alive expanded and so the
truth is
your natural state believe it or not
is to be on the energized expanded side
of the internal compass that's in you
and so you are never really lost i'm
telling you this i know you may feel
lost i know you may feel defeated i know
you may feel depleted i know you may
feel stuck these are all temporary
states and one of the fastest ways for
you to start to change
how you feel about where you are in your
life is to tune inward and to start to
read the energy because if you feel
stuck your natural energy is depleted if
you feel despair your natural energy is
depleted and the fastest way to start to
shift that is to shift the energy inside
you and to start to align your life
towards things that energize you now
i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy but
before that it's time for the question
of the day i want to know what was your
single biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week the science says that when you just
watch a video you get motivated to get
inspired you have a 35 chance of
following through on your goals 35
that's not enough that's not enough just
to get motivated believe nation we're
here you're here today matters you're an
action taker
when you commit to a plan of action of
when and how you're going to follow
through when you write it down you have
a 91 chance of following through and
when you commit publicly to somebody
else that jumps to 95 percent chance
from 30 something percent to 95 chance
of you following through believe nation
we need to make this happen so question
of the day your single biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
specific for the next week put it down
in the comments below and i'm going to
show on screen
sometime next week to celebrate you
schedule your due time what i want you
to do is plan for one hour every single
day if you're an entrepreneur one hour
every day where you're doing pick a time
ideally i think morning like if you get
in at nine then nine to ten first hour
of the day but if it's not then blocking
the account this is important
this is what will change your life this
is what will change the trajectory of
your business if you are stuck
constantly and just responding to people
and playing planning perfectionist mode
do time right we said do it daily point
number one now you got to schedule it in
just have an intention won't do anything
if you're not actually taking action on
it right you're not doing the thing that
you promise to do you're not doing the
doing the progress that you will make
the closer you get to your goals will be
a reflection of what you are putting in
your calendar what you are actually
doing so i want you to schedule one hour
today of due time every single day we're
gonna be making something and pushing it
up to the world anyone that you wanna
let's say uh uh go against anybody you
don't like anybody that's as pleased as
you anybody you want revenge for anybody
that you hate anything you remember that
someone did bad to you
let it go
forgive them
you don't have to say it out loud you
could say to yourself i forgive you
people you really really hate it's
amazing what happens amazing
something lifts off your shoulder
and the negative isn't as strong as it
was before this is amazing thing that
cost absolutely nothing i cannot change
yesterday's newspaper i'm not gonna let
it burn me down because by being in my
subconscious mind
everything around me looks bleaker
because i had this bad stuff happen to
me before that i want a revenge or that
i hate it's still in that subconscious
mind get it out of there get it out
there by saying i forgive you no matter
how bad they work i forgive you no
matter how much revenge you want i
forgive you no matter how just it is or
injustice i forgive you it lifts the
burden off you so when these little
things start happening and they're
little things now but they're actually
gigantic to you now in the future you
would have gone through it it would have
been smaller but one way to make it
smaller now is get off your shoulder out
of your mind all that disrespect all
that hate all that revenge all that
jealousy get them out of there forgive
everybody for just forgive them and
you'd be amazed within 24 hours maybe
for one hour something is just lifted
off your shoulders this is one good
direction to start going into and it
doesn't hurt anything to meditate and if
you don't know how to meditate just sit
there close your eyes sit upright close
your eyes put your hands wherever you
want and just uh close your eyes and
just look at a white light in front of
you if there isn't one in front of you
mock one up if different things enter
your mind the thought that could enter
your mind is i am i am part of god i am
and then you can focus on something and
if you can do that for 20 minutes in the
morning and 20 minutes at late afternoon
or at night you'll be amazed at how
freer your body is and how less tense
you are about the problems we have today
every morning what do you reach for
uh well i read
uh new york times wall street journal
the economist is sort of my regular
weekly fair um
he can give you
last week's by memory i mean he doesn't
work
that's great it's great to have
something you read on a regular basis
and they do special sections um
charlie what do you read well i agree
with bill i think the best one
publication i read is the economist
which is interesting yeah well i read
that but i i read the local paper i read
the ft i read the wall street journal i
read the new york times and i and i read
usa today i sold fax machines
door-to-door for seven years after
graduating from college
and i
you know
for 20 years spanx is going to be 20. i
started it in the year 2000 and um
the sound bite in the media has been
sarah cut the feet out of pantyhose and
solved an undergarment issue and you
know now spanx is here and and while
that is true there was so much more
about the behind the scenes of why this
happened and people have asked me can i
have 10 minutes 15 minutes of your time
i want to pick your brain on how spanx
started but the real answer is it
started way before i cut the feet out of
my pantyhose and it it it started when i
was much younger and i had a series of
kind of tragic events happen to me when
i was in high school and it led me to
wayne dyer who is a motivational
inspirational speaker he passed away
about two years ago but i got exposed to
him and i listened to his cassette tapes
over and over and over again to the
point that i had his one series called
how to be a no limit person
memorized all 10 cassette tapes front
and back
and try living with that
well yeah that's funny because in high
school no one wanted to get stuck in my
car like after a party they're like
she's gonna make you listen to the [ __ ]
and so
um but then you know i said i said i
think i would take simple things like
i'm just gonna do the laundry tomorrow
and she'd be like do you know the
ramifications of waiting till tomorrow
like
so um but then fast forward you know i
think it was 10 to 15 years after high
school that um i ended up on the cover
of forbes and the texts i got in my
phone were so funny i mean literally all
my friends were like
should have listened to that
so but i'm a big believer in it i
learned early on about manifesting law
of attraction not caring what other
people think about you which is a really
big one for an entrepreneur or you know
in life really and i'm a work in
progress on that there are times where i
do care and i check myself and say you
know let's let's work on this but it's
very freeing to not care what other
people think you'll take more risks
um to not really focus on the outcome
and be so afraid to fail so all of that
is a big part of my journey and and
spanx for sure so i think mindset is
i work on it daily usually before the
sun comes up
i
offer myself to something greater than
myself
if it's for one minute 20 seconds or 10
minutes i at least stop in that space in
my house every morning
i have a little meditation space where i
just go i have beautiful spiritual
readings there i light my three candles
there
daily word or something and i express
to this greater energy field than i
that
i don't want to be alone as i move out
into the world i teach people
that daily you have to prime yourself
you have to do something for 10 minutes
minimum if you don't have 10 minutes you
don't have a life
and ooh that's so good i mean i just
like you've got to do it right that's
good if you don't have 10 minutes you
don't have life to give to priming
yourself that's right
prime life you want a beautiful life
beautiful family i'm so i'm so i i i
love that you said what i do the first
time i wake up in the morning yeah
people always ask me how do you sew up
all the time but probably as i attend
all these seminars you know i teach all
this but the real reason is you prime
yourself i primed myself that's what
i've done for years it's like i've
changed my body with this radical
breathing pattern or movement there's
many ways to do it but then i do through
10 minutes and i do it usually goes more
because i'm enjoying it yeah but 10
minutes is how i get myself to do it
three and a half minutes of pure
gratitude about three things
and i take one of those three to be
simple because i don't want to be the
astronaut that you know he went to the
moon that was his idea adventure and
then they all come back we're depressed
because what do i do for the rest of my
life yes so the wind on my face you know
my children's faces um anything and the
reason for gratitude is
the two emotions that mess us up the
most are fear and anger yeah and you
can't be grateful and fearful
simultaneously they don't go together
and you can't be angry and grateful
simultaneously so if you literally start
your day cultivating that this part is
talking about creating a highway to
happiness yeah and then i do three
minutes of my three to thrive what are
three outcomes and results i'm really
committed to and i see them as done and
fulfilled and then that day
i usually look at something at six
months to twelve months out something
that's a little bigger and then
what i feel is fulfilled and done i give
thanks for it
and you're at the end of those 10
minutes and usually it's 15 or 18 for me
i am so wired now i've done that for
years it's been the base of me
what's different with suffering
is measuring it moment to moment oprah
and then the third one for me is okay
how do i love more because love to me is
an action it's not a word it's not an
emotion it's like if you love you act
accordingly so love and what can i do in
a loving way and that what could i be
grateful for and that little three-step
process
ends the suffering when you find
yourself under stress
and anxiety things go wrong you get
disappointments
things don't work out as you hoped you
must feel a moment of anxiety a moment
of stress how do you deal with that what
happens
um
i can
go out of the stress
i can at
any moment like there are times when i i
feel the stress of the circumstances
and then i can
at will
go out of that stress
and just
see things
in a different way and it makes me feel
um almost like a ninja you know when the
in the ninja everything seems to come in
slow motion
you know and in the sense you could step
back and it's coming at me
at slow motion and i can deal with it in
in a way that makes me feel more
centered and in control but like tennis
players they say at the height of their
game
the ball seems to go much slower the
whole game slows down yeah and it's
really
that
equanimity that produces that kind of a
reaction as distinct from
when you have the anxiety i always try
to hire people that are smarter than me
and that complement my skills skill sets
like i'm a ready fire aim guy and i
always try to partner with people that
are very anal and perfectionist to kind
of balance me out or have a skill set
that i don't have um but once i'm going
i mean i would go to events and like
this and listen and learn and go to
conferences and when i get the
opportunity i'll ask questions but i'm
not i i can't ever say ever what i've
said
i'm going to call this guy and just see
what he thinks for this woman and just
ask that's just not my style i mean
because at some point i'm going to have
to be responsible for whatever that
knowledge is
and and and also i have the benefit of
being in the technology business and
it's it's a benefit because there's
always something new coming and i've
always had the attitude that whatever it
is so if it's virtual reality if it's
the oculus rift it's new to everybody
except the people who invented it and so
i'm i'm at first base like everybody
else and then it's just a question of
effort of learning it as well as
everybody else so other than going to
the originator of the idea concept
product service whatever
i'm tied with everybody else and and
having the opportunity to learn it so
i'll just put in the time to learn it so
from a tech perspective and that that's
always served me well because once you
understand these different products you
understand how they fit together and it
also helps you make decisions and
understand what will work and what won't
work certainly being focused on
something that you're confident will
have high value to someone else
and just being really rigorous in making
that assessment um because people
tend to
a natural human tendency is wishful
thinking
um so a challenge for entrepreneurs is
to say well what's the difference
between really believing in your ideals
and sticking to sticking to them
versus
pursuing some unrealistic dream that
doesn't actually have merit and it's
it's that is a that is a really
difficult thing to to tell you can you
tell the difference between those two
things right now so you need to be sort
of very rigorous
in your self
self analysis
i think certainly extremely tenacious
uh and
um
and then just work like hell i mean you
just have to put in
you know 80-hour 80-100 hour
weeks every week
and then a lot of work that all those
things improve the odds of success okay
um
i mean if if if other people are putting
in 40 hour work weeks and you're putting
in 100 hour work weeks then even if
uh you're doing the same thing you know
that in in one year you will achieve
what they achieve you will achieve
in four months what it takes them a year
to achieve
[Music]
oh it's cold this morning
you can beat that freaking thing up
get up before it is
gives you a sense of
i'm winning man i hadn't even done
anything all i did was get out of bed
[Music]
so dr you know i dressed for success man
i got to grab my favorite watch
[Music]
spend probably 15 or 20 minutes a day
just responding beat the sun up see that
that encourages him
and he encourages me
it just works it works we all we all
help each other
[Music]
[Music]
bob
[Music]
listen to the birds
i hope you're gonna have a great day
today because i am
i have a great day if it's a bad day i'm
gonna turn it into a great day
because that's what i do
some of some of the days that have
started out bad for me have been the
best days of my life
you just gotta hang in there you gotta
stay in there
you gotta keep pushing and shoving and
say dude i'm gonna make a bad day a
great i'm gonna flip this thing i'm
gonna turn it on its head it's just a
day
just today let me turn this thing you
turn enough bad days into great days
you'll end up with a great life if we're
not fit and healthy we're not gonna be
able to achieve anything so
um you know so you know i will swim
around the island uh every day or i'll
you know go kite surfing or i'll play
tennis or i'll you know i'll do
something to make sure that the body is
healthy and the endorphins are running
and
and and then i can throw myself into
work um
and i suspect
um at least 50 of my time is sort of
setting up not-for-profit
organizations in the world to tackle you
know some of some of the bigger problems
of the world um and
you know the other 50 i suspect is
diving in and out on you know some of
our businesses around the world you know
maybe doing a bit of firefighting when
things are going wrong
or
you know giving them a push you know
when things are going right i wanted to
give you some specific insights on the
value of rising before the sun and
joining the 5 a.m club which is a
concept i've been teaching to my
billionaire clients and ceo clients and
executives at companies like starbucks
and fedex and ibm and nike and other
organizations that i've worked with for
over the past two decades with
tremendous success in terms of helping
them increase their focus their energy
their productivity and their performance
so
there's a reason why
the visionary founder of starbucks
howard schultz rises before the sun
there's a reason why michelle obama
rises very early there's a reason why
tim cook who's leading apple
gets up before the dawn first of all the
hours between four and six are the time
of least distraction in this age of
dramatic interruption
number two
the hours before the sun rises is the
period where your brain is most
available to your primary creativity
so while you're sleeping your brain
actually washes itself but also it lets
it go the residue of the previous day
while you are resting and while you are
recovering when you wake up your
thinking is fresh your creativity is
most pristine you are most available
to access
your gifts and your talents so
those are some of the reasons why i
encourage you to get a brill you might
say robin well i'm not an early riser i
can't put mind over mattress i can't win
the battle of the bed grandma never got
up early dad couldn't get up early i
guess i'm not the kind of person who can
rise before the sun and what i would
suggest to you is simply this
[Music]
what science confirms in particular the
data of university college london you do
any new habit practice it for 66 days
and you will arrive at the place of
automaticity in other words it'll be
easier to run the new habit than not to
66 days
of rising at 5 am will get you to a
place where it's easier to get up to 5
am then not to get up at 5am you'll
reach a place of automaticity
in my book the 5am club i say all change
is hard at first and it's messy in the
middle and it's gorgeous
at the end i'll repeat that again
because it's so important all changes
hard at first
messy in the middle and it's gorgeous at
the end what time do you get up normally
in the morning
for me it's usually about seven seven
okay
um but i go to bed late so usually it's
i go to bed around one a.m or so one a.m
yeah
and you start day with a real breakfast
or just for the coffee or with the water
you know that also varies a lot um i i
think it's probably true that if you
that having a good breakfast is is a
good idea but um usually i don't have
time for that so
um
sometimes uh sometimes it's it's made
for me but
um probably half the time
i don't have any breakfast i had let's
have like coffee or something like that
you guys are just getting started
you're not gonna start right here
you're gonna start down there okay
probably in another city another town i
grew up in lake charles louisiana no
money raised by a single mother i was in
debt at 25 years old the first thing
that i had to do in my life was not
learn a new skill
first thing i had to do to get my life
moving in the right direction was
self-development
it is vital it was vital for me that i
improved myself and i could start
depending upon me i had to show up every
day with some rituals some disciplines
and start getting myself to trust me not
trust others but trust myself to do the
right thing every day one of the things
that i started doing was beating the sun
up every morning
i'm gonna beat that sun up every morning
so that i had the discipline and the
control over my life
so i knew hey before that thing pops
i'm gonna pop i'm gonna get out of bed
depend on myself get up at the same time
every day and for me that time
regardless of where i was was beat that
sun up no matter where i am i'm gonna
beat that thing up so it gives me a
sense of control over my own life second
thing i had to start cleaning up my life
and my friends and my environment
when i was younger between 15 and 25 i
was doing crazy stuff in my life
wasting my weekends i had the same
weekends or for the week
i was drinking
fooling around with a bunch of bad
things bad people
making poor choices
at 25 years old i cleaned it all up quit
going to those places quit using those
things
quit hanging out with people that did
not have ethics and discipline in their
life that weren't committed to the same
things that i was
i wanted to build something in my life i
wanted to become someone and to do that
to become someone in the eyes of the
world the first thing i had to do was
become someone i could depend on
so put some things together three or
four things you can do every day to
start the day
kick start your day
get going in your day to give you a
sense of respect for yourself
accomplishment for yourself look just
beating that sun up every morning gives
me the sense of accomplishment that i
did what i said said i was gonna do that
i woke up when i said i would wake up
and i start building respect for myself
start believing in myself so that i can
go out into the world and maybe maybe
maybe today
maybe today when i go into this meeting
that i'm dressed for maybe they'll
believe in me as much as i believe in me
and that'll show up in a contract a deal
maybe even some money you must come up
with a morning routine
that you do
every single morning or at least more
mornings than not
that puts you in control of yourself
and in control of your day this is what
i do
and i cannot explain the power that i
get
from starting my day off and being
bigger than my excuses and being in
control
first and foremost wake up on time when
that alarm goes off get your butt out of
bed five four three two one go why is
that important for persistence the
reason why is because the first decision
that you're making of the day is to
actually get up and get moving that
means you are
persistently
bigger than your excuses you are
persistently bigger than feeling lazy
and you are persistently beating the
feelings that typically stop you
the second thing that i want you to do
before you look at your email
before you answer your phone before you
start surfing vox and vice and buzzfeed
and you know team stream and checking
out the sales on zappos and looking at
your facebook news feed before you pick
up the phone
please please please
figure out your two priorities for the
day
these are the things that matter to you
whether it's saving money and and making
sure you're focused on that or showing
up at work and being a contributor or
whether it's changing how you treat your
spouse or your kids or the person that
you're with or heck getting to the gym
because you said you would whatever it
is that your two priorities are
put them in your head before you pick up
the phone why
the reason why
is because of persistence the reason why
is because i want you to have a good day
do you know what makes for a bad day
what makes for a bad day is
snoozing
starting your day off late starting your
day off tired starting your day off by
mainlining everybody else's news feed on
social media and looking at everybody
else's life and and saying to yourself
oh my god they're on vacation or gosh
they look so great or their friends are
so fancy or my gosh they've got some
money
you start off your day looking at that
you're never gonna have a good day you
gotta start off your day by getting up
on time figuring out your priorities and
then getting to work on them do not pick
up your phone until you have done those
two things i think the single biggest
reason why people have bad days is
because they start them off by looking
around at everybody else and seeing what
they're doing instead of having the
focus and the discipline
to actually start your day off with you
in control and with your priorities
front and center so you want a bonus
round exercise every day that's right
get up on time figure out your
priorities and exercise you do those
three things you'll be kicking ass every
single day do you think you do so well
in business because you're dedicated to
looking after your body and leading an
active lifestyle
100 i think if you can find an hour or
two a day for yourself
for your body then you're going to be
able to do
you know five or six more hours of
creativity throughout the day and and we
all know you know when we let ourselves
go
you know we're just not going to perform
as well so
you know one of the reasons we've set up
health clubs
in pretty well every you know all the
major cities around the world is
um you know it is it is a passion of
mine i think it's so important that
people you know
keep healthy i mean the balance of work
and play is critical
and i think a lot of people don't get
that balance right you know i'm 63 years
old now so uh critical to
find time for yourself and get out there
and keep fit and and i find the best way
of keeping fit is by playing
i try to
encourage our chief executives worldwide
to make sure that there's as much
flexibility in in the workplace as
possible
we've set up something called the b team
which is examining the way companies
treat their staff and trying to make
suggestions to make the dignity of work
better than it's been in the past
[Music]
if you're too close to a situation you
know like in an office you get bogged
down with the menu tie
if you can step away from the situation
you can think about the bigger picture
and that's what i am able to do on mecca
the most extraordinary people come to
necca the elders was conceived here on
necca with archbishop tutu with
president carter with kofi annan
the carbon wall room was conceived here
an organization that tries to work with
industry to try to extract carbon out of
the earth's atmosphere
you know sitting in muhammad looking up
at the stars at night things like virgin
galactic
so great place to think and a great
place to conceive ideas
we had a fantastic day it was a sunday
so it wasn't all work so um a great way
of capping off the day watch the super
bowl with a cup of tea and uh
and a chair
start preparing the night before
most people have great morning routines
they start the night before when you
actually have a little bit more time so
instead of trying to cram everything in
to that
hectic ridiculously crazy morning
help make it easier for yourself by
planning a little bit more the night
before so if you're one of your goals is
to exercise and to run more the night
before set out your shoes set up your
exercise gear set up your clothes so
that all you have to do is wake up and
put them on if one of your goals is to
eat healthier and you're tired of going
out and eating mcdonald's for lunch or
whatever it is then the night before
plan your lunch make a sandwich make a
salad
create something healthy have some
snacks you can just go to the fridge
pull out your bag and you're off to work
today's my video day
when i know what it's my video day the
night before i set up my camera i set up
my gear set up my microphone it's all
ready for me to go so all i have to do
is walk in and press record and i'm
ready to go make it easy for yourself
don't cram more into your morning
prepare the night before man what's your
morning routine
every morning without fail the first
thing i do is i run
without fail i haven't missed a day of
running since 2016. okay so i get up i
do that four days out of the week i go
to the gym and every single night
for five and a half years i stretch out
for at least two hours that was a killer
part of the book every
night that is that's where i so when you
go so hard
mentally physically emotionally
spiritually you have to have time set
aside to quiet
and recover
recovery is big the mind especially the
mind and the body
this is my time there's no phone calls
there's no emails the world does not
exist
because i have to get ready for it
tomorrow yeah get the body opened up why
because as i won't get you know two
years
but your body's getting tight yeah
you go hard tom a lot of people go hard
what happens is that stress yep starts
to tighten up that psoas muscle hip
flexors so lower back you got back
problems all of a sudden you have no
idea why it's all tightness it's all
tightness man because you're constantly
charged and going hard four o'clock in
the morning i wake up have my caffeine
walk in the morning four o'clock in the
morning but by the way that's the magic
hour that four o'clock in the morning is
when no one else is up so no one else is
bothering you and you can focus on
whatever work you have to get done i'm
sending these electronic mails those
things right i've heard
those things
and then by 4 30 45 i'm doing some sort
of cardio so in this case i come out
here open these garage doors uh it's
still dark outside so it's just me and a
whole bunch of blair witch things that
are happening out there in the woods
and i jump on this thing i do this and
then i'll have breakfast and then i will
go do all my strength and conditioning
training at a gym
for about an hour and then i'll go to
set so total workout time for all the
dudes that are like i could look like
that at home right now how much run time
cardio and strength do you do a day
between cardio
strength and resistance training
stretching maybe about an hour and 45
minutes okay that's not too bad not too
bad too bad it's not all in one shot
okay you have to be watching your diet
because we know diet like they say abs
are made in the kitchen so more than
you're working out diets everything i
can tell you right now is just to find
balance as well okay so it's a little
bit of everything yeah sure so i think
carbs are your friend if you practice
any new skill for 66 days in a row
through the power of
neuroplasticity which is the brain's
ability to adapt
then you are going to reach a point
called automaticity i want you to think
about that term automaticity in other
words after 66 days of practicing the 20
20 20 formula
and joining the 5 a.m club and running
the morning routine you're going to get
to a point where it's automatic you're
going to get to a point where it's
actually easier to get up at 5 a.m than
to stay in bed
i also want to offer you a brain tattoo
from the book to consider as you wire in
this morning protocol of billionaires
and highly creative people professional
athletes and industry titans and it's
this all change is hard at first and
it's messy in the middle and it's
beautiful at the end i'm going to repeat
that again for you because it's so
important all change is hard at first if
a new skill or a new routine or a new
habit was easy
then it wouldn't be valuable change
so anything that's valuable
is hard at first you know society says
live an easy life i suggest to you that
whether it's a great morning routine
whether it's building a great business
whether it's releasing your master work
to the world maybe it's a great
relationship maybe it's a great interior
life
it takes real effort it takes the long
game it takes focus it takes hard work
it takes bravery
but the rewards are so much more
glorious than living an easy life okay
so and also remember the things you once
found difficult
you now find easy little kids for
example find walking early on difficult
or learning a new nursery rhyme or
learning how to read or learning how to
build relationships at first there's not
a lot of facility and fluency with those
skills because every skill is difficult
at first until you practice it and then
train until you get to a place where you
master it and so your morning routine is
going to be challenging at first but
with daily training and practicing the
20 20 20 formula i promise you you're
going to get to a point of mastery
and then the payoffs are extraordinary
your creativity will soar your
productivity will maximize you will
actually attract more prosperity into
your life because the marketplace
rewards true creativity and productivity
you're going to feel so much more
happier in your day you're going to find
that sense of peacefulness so it's
almost like you go through a life with a
greater level of grace and ease you know
the way you start your day determines
the way your day is going to unfold
[Music]
if you want to know what else
billionaires do daily check out the
video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there and then i can
at will
go out of that stress
first thing i had to do to get my life
moving in the right direction was
self-development
it is vital